a las dos de la tarde de washington el
presidente joe biden enumera
oficialmente aquitania y brown action
como la próxima juez de la corte suprema
de justicia de eeuu máximo órgano
judicial de este país será el reemplazo
de stephen breyer quien renunció a su
cargo para dar la oportunidad a que un
juez de tendencia liberal más joven
pudiera ser elegido aprovechando no
solamente el poder ejecutivo sino
también la mayoría en el congreso que
tiene el partido demócrata hay que
mencionar que estos cargos son
vitalicios y sólo se renuevan tras la
renuncia o la muerte de algún magistrado
jackson es de 51 años será la primera
mujer afroamericana en ocupar este cargo
después de su experiencia como juez de
apelaciones en la corte del circuito del
distrito de columbia en washington y
tras su amplia experiencia también como
fiscal en defensa criminal para ser
confirmadas sin embargo su cargo faltará
la aprobación del senado en donde
demócratas tienen apenas una mayoría
simple y donde hay mucho rechazo a esta
nominación por parte de senadores
republicanos como cruz y lindsey graham
entre otros